[Applause]
stephen was
right behind me okay well we might just
pour to him because they're apart of
australia
um
i had to stop with dan gordon um and
nibble after santa prayed
[Applause]
yes
okay
[Applause]
is the facilitator we were still sitting
in the ashley riverbed
looking at some lovely birds and then we
got to wood
and our former passengers said hey hey i
don't throw them under a bust
my keys oh yeah
[Applause]
marietta
good afternoon folks um
apologies for the slight delay and
kicking off today we've been uh
having a very interesting field trip
into the ashley riverbed
so it just took a wee bit longer to get
back
so we're on to our last water meeting
for what has been uh
mixed up here but we've basically got to
the end of one piece so we're very
fortunate
stephen could you please open the
meeting with us here
[Applause]
thank you steven um apologies
do we have any apologies mr cam
henderson has a family
full of sickness so he decided to stay
away
anyone else um
is on route um been in touch while we've
been field tripping
anymore we'll start with that curry um
so i have a mover please for apologies
erin thank you seconded
windy thank you everybody happy with
those
all those in favor carrie
thank you
so as i mentioned before it's um the
last for 2020.
um murray you to my immediate left if
you could introduce yourself please
we're still taping these and they are
available if you would like to listen to
the meeting again
in the space of the next 24 hours
they'll be available
here everyone murray griffin facilitator
for the committee
david hp community member stewart
district council representative john
cook
[Applause]
community
environment concrete by
henry andreas
cannery foreign
[Music]
thank you i'm michael blackwell the
current chair
so again with the audio there we don't
have individual microphones so possibly
if we can
announce our vowels clearly please thank
you
speak proper english um registration of
interest do we have
any changes updates
nothing there lovely
item two opportunity for the public to
speak
michael the floor is yours sir
michael bates hey
afternoon everybody here today until we
get the silver stream of the downward
climbing 128 thousand dollars
sorry this is the cardboard living the
slabs you need a bit of
hand to love and care on these plants
we're going to spend money on planting
only things you look after actually weed
around them not to program
there's another one required for it
you just see the plants poking through
the bushes
these are actually healthier than ones
at the silver screen and they need a bit
of
tender love and chair
now this is a silkscreen have been
sprayed around
quite a few of them being filled with
spray
i'm going to spend this sort of money
can we look after them please
same scenario there are
portions of them they have grown quite
well in the long grass some of them
about four feet high but this
effect percentage like this button then
kill it
that's the sentiment
[Music]
okay
one
um
so if the success rate falls below
[Applause]
so just to be super clear that yes the
considerable amount of money has been
spent in there
it is maintenance contract is part of
the whole contract planning projects out
and that's across three years and so and
it's got um performance
measures in it so we'll be following it
through so just to be absolutely
reassured
there is expectations within the
contract within this planting
we'll follow up on this but we do need
to expect it to be some that don't make
mom
[Applause]
so
oh
2017.
one mil now
there's the capital on the right it
sticks on the left by the way
on the right
that's the courtney stream
[Applause]
well i'm standing in if you looked at
all these pictures
you're thinking in the same room
that's behaviour
that's part of the l2 spring running
into the outside
runs down into a stormwater pond which
has literally got no life in it
whatsoever
and it's huge 300 meters long like about
150 meters high
full of rushes nothing else virtually no
waterfowl
no baby guts nothing next one
now that's the sticks river two years
ago
next month you wouldn't know the
difference would you
that's the lt today you went here today
that's what it looked like
it's only about a week old that fatter
from the left there you can see a white
line on the board there
that's where the water used to be when
they had weed in it
hasn't been mechanically removed
this should be full of weed with
nitrates in the water
nothing virtually no fish like at all i
saw two wheels going upstream
hardly any bullets just been
chemically cleaned that's what i told
him
how are we even going to put my head out
there to pull the tributaries and
running into it
yes
it's a side street running into the l2
it looks like you get
up again just been wiped out
next one another stream that's
flanking in the foreground there we can
see the houses
same scenario
last year downstream further looked like
a headphone javier
mechanically with bowls of dirt on the
ground i looked about two
one to two years old again
no life enough how are we ever going to
fix anything by treating them like this
you treated your dairy farm like this
you wouldn't have any cows on it
next one just what the sticks
they kept the tiny stream looked like
two years ago you can't tell the
difference
we trying to improve things you've got
to be kidding
50 100 percent wheat virtually or 95
percent weight
and it's 99.9 nowhere
hundreds of thousand dollars of planting
on the horsepower
we've got now a great light from that
it's been right also
because when they've got plantings along
both sides right there
they're not chemically spraying down the
moon
is
and your idea with the causes of that
um i think we're all on the same page
we're concerned about that lack of
aquatic cover because it's just
throughout all of our loads of waterways
it's just it's not there
so i would really appreciate at a point
in time
and i know we've asked this before but
tim possibly if you could oversee
i mean can we pin down a causal effect
that might be running parallel to
michael's theory
and the l2 i was absolutely
gutted and shocked to see it in the last
month i could not believe what i saw
when i was out there
it's just and it's very like what
happened in the sticks
two years ago um
we've and adrian and i and a couple
others have talked about it but
trying to get um a better handle on this
particularly from neewer
who uh you know done a lot of work
around aquatic systems
and and what grows in these low-level
systems because what
seems to happen is they just collapse
and the l2 isn't actually plastic and
the sticks was as well um but the six
has recovered to a certain extent
and this is what's really really
confusing
it's not easy to pin it down in a last
day dream you
pick up from here but but we have
started um you know it was
for me it was cml2 but it wasn't just
because of the l2 it was also
you know what happens on the sticks and
what we've seen and it's not
[Applause]
yeah thank you michael and and i
recreate the same as
as their chair is saying none of us like
what's sitting here and it is a problem
um and it's distressing that it's
happening on
river after river after river
you're telling us that it's toxic
herbicides that are doing it with
struggle very difficultly to actually
tie down
that that is the cause it's it's a very
obvious lot
it's an obvious explanation but we're
trying to find who might be actually
putting herbicides in these rivers we
have been talking to niwa i spent about
an hour with a team leader of
flem methods and at new wire hamilton
last week because they're working on us
on similar issues they're seeing in the
hawke's bay and harrah's
planes in the waikato they're working
for the christchurch city council at the
moment on the sticks
and um and they're producing a they're
going to be putting together a two-page
um sort of position paper for us
they would say that it's three possible
reasons why these the streams go like
this and become critical as
tim is suggesting it could just be
excessive amounts of fine sediment
smothering the
macrophytes just collapse and can't do
it in several places they're finding
anoxia too much organic material
accumulating in the sediment
the sediment is to be going anoxic no
oxygen and that kills the plants
or it could be herbicides or it could be
a mixture of all three
tying that down is very difficult my
colleague
don't engrave last year basically and
michael he worked with you did a load of
sampling of herbicides and sediment
herbicides and water and a number of
these waterways
and didn't detect them which is really
difficult now is that definitive reason
that it's not
i don't think so we were actually
talking to other researchers
like christophe mattai at university of
otago and niwa
on on sampling systems that accumulate
these herbicides
in what we call passable disorders that
sort of just accumulated into a media
for over about three months that we have
an old body we are committed to trying
to find out what's causing this we are
looking at different opportunities
we are working with nega because we
don't want this to keep happening either
thank you for coming along and drawing
our attention to us we are concerned and
i'm not sure what more i can say other
than that we're
doing as much as we can and working with
the other researchers because we don't
want to reinvent the wheel
we don't want to duplicate what new is
doing elsewhere we want to work with
nemara and other researchers so that we
get a solution that's not just for
canterbury but for all new zealand as
well
i'll live with that at the moment sorry
michael
here yep
you talk about nitrates in the water
almost 100 weight and it should be
choked before
michael is finding people that might
might be discharging herbicides to the
waterways
that are even purchasing level and
discharging them it's done too perfectly
to not really know what they do
they know exactly how much stuff to put
in there but we need
years in the lake
it's a cheap way of cleaning around
cheap maintenance
in my opinion i can't accuse everyone
that's actually doing it does that
happen on your dairy farm
what would you do you
if you don't you land your distillery
landscape
last year i've been told it's frost
it
it's been absolutely wiped out keep the
driveway they clean what are you gonna
put on
chemicals and they say they can't find
any
we're in the 21st century
why the hell can't we go you can do
everything else
there's no wall power to fix it because
this is the cheapest way of doing it
it looks beautiful i breathe looking at
that the average person wouldn't know
the difference
what's there a natured fish life is
virtually gone
and that's not acceptable shouldn't be
sick by anyone in this room
you can need to kick up the ass and
kneeler whoever's in control needs to
kick up the earth
i'm sorry for the language i'm not
trying to look at anyone personally
but this is not acceptable in new
zealand
what tourists in their right mind want
to come to our country we claim we're
the cleanest in the world
this is absolutely ridiculous
know what something we've done about it
i've been coming here for four years he
did the same thing
2012 the guy boy river was flying
he had millions and millions of shrimps
and bullies and everything
the nitrates are still quite high in the
silver strap the silver strings but
not affected because the salmon hatching
on
you don't want to just do it that way
it must be nice
but we can do better we have to do
better
to sit down as four years and they've
actually ignored me
this is what i've showed you today
because we can't anymore we've got to
fix it
and how can we do better if you don't
know where it's coming from they know
where it's coming from they don't know
where it's coming from they'd have to do
it for the job
please stay
thinking all right before you just say
what you can talk to any freshman
vision for 50 years and they're all
staged chemicals
have they seen the discharge though yeah
it's you know we tried very hard
for compliance discharges in the
customize
the next week the guy was rolled over
and spraying right across the ground
because we're right with you the aquatic
plants this um is the aquatic habitat
for the fish and the shrimps
that's the outcomes
where the downstream
[Applause]
the only place we know that the
herbicides are discharged into the water
water to kill herbicides
is in the open river at first reach
which is to kill
a noxious plant interior denser which
we're trying to contain to that which
city council is trying to contain to
that site
and and to remove but that's the only
site where we're aware of
that people that there's deliberate
discharge of
herbicides into the water column down
the road
from there down to the botanical garden
this gets worse and worse and worse
you get downstream by the way austria
and we start to come in
well i was talking to them last week and
they were promising me a two-page
proposal this week
because i'm thinking that we want to be
working with them and other councils
well it's intense to scope out what they
think the causes might be
and and the scope of works it might be
to try to clarify this problem
you know we could roll our sleeves up
and try to dive into ourselves but it
makes
it doesn't make sense to do it when
other organizations have the same
problem
we'd like to tackle it once and for all
so fleur was promising me a two-page
proposal this week okay
9 500 percent weed and down from 50
meters
no right down to the estee river
i'm as confused as everyone in this room
and concern
um the technology we've got today they
don't know the answer
is
[Music]
them
there's another stream running into the
l2 just
just upstream from there it actually
comes
and that's what it should look like
that's what the l2 looked like two years
ago
all our lowland springs should look
roughly like that
and that's not actually over health
it's quite nutrient rich but but the
macro and the macrophytes are the
habitat of the shrimps the habitat with
the
eels the habitat of the small and the
bullies and galaxies and things like
that
and and a lot of that macrophage often
has it has a colloquial term of being
trout wheat
because that's where you'll find off in
the trout from an exotic
position because it's where the insects
and the in the
mice and shrimps and the paratha shrimps
will be and they'll be feeding
so yes yes macrophytes are an
important part of the habitat for these
always because they provide the habitat
that's otherwise uniform and barren like
most of michael's photographs
and it's that habitat that is the
supermarket for the fish
and the ducklings which we're not seeing
a lot of at the moment because there's
nothing from deep
when i went to the until i've been all
day there i saw one
mallard hand in full young
years ago when you see the trout fishing
that drive yesterday
every 50 meters in their clutch
[Applause]
all right questions with michael
thanks mate but i appreciate you i know
you find this incredibly frustrating
but keep your voice out there
[Music]
[Applause]
um here maybe we should record
the appearance of a couple i do members
lovely
[Applause]
uh item three we have a three waters
update sophie could you please join us
who has a specific special
just do a quick update for it so there
was a bit of a
general run-through of five reasons
action points from last meeting uh
michael bates showed as a of
beachgrove
with the management i think about four
years ago
where there were no plants and quite
muddy looking and then now
so i did confirm that that was a change
the
asset was vested in the council about
three years ago
maybe four uh and uh schoolnet engineer
i'm sort of planting in that area after
the best thing so that is
good to know that that yeah
[Applause]
the contract is out so far we haven't
had any
uni dead birds it's not even started
last week but we haven't had any
um signs of canadian botulism yet to our
wastewater treatment plants
it's fingers crossed and stays low we
still might get
you know the occasional bird that might
died maybe in watches or something
something else but we're hoping not to
have
numbers like we had a few years ago
[Applause]
with any particular um rather than going
through all the points i'm happy to
ask questions together i could also note
that what wasn't in the update is
the kayak lakes um so our green space
team look after the kaikoura lakes you
might remember
we proposed to put in monitoring of
summertime with oxygen probes
today we um we were supposed to put
both of them in last week but
unfortunately one of the probes
malfunctioned
before we put it in so we've already put
in one then we'll put in the second
oxygen probe
next week so that will be over
summertime we'll have both temperature
and oxygen being long just above the
surface and down below and it will show
where the game
aeration might be a is solution for
those snakes
just a question about the maintenance
money works water is consented
which
yeah so if we just if we did decide to
take works
with any areas of your sequencing
replication so we didn't want it to hold
up the this
customer because it's quite a big new
thing to add in yeah and we don't
actually know
that the wetlands map hasn't there's no
planning map
um at the moment we have to survey yeah
so we're just gonna do a case-by-case
basis we think it's considered a wetland
yeah actually there's good news with
that i think i can tell you that
as of today we've approved
colony
[Music]
you're
no i think it's very appropriate
locations of youtube yeah
so thank you for having me my name is
sylvia i run a small environmental
consultancy called storm environmental
and i've been to continent to
lead this project for one career
registry councils
so this is what we're going to talk
about today i'll keep it really brief i
realize you have another site visiting
your christmas
dinner so you're not going
to get about 15 slides just on this
product so we'll just run through
um basically we're here
basically right in the middle of my
project as it were so uh we're focusing
on two areas in kaikou where there's
been some pretty bad flooding in the
past
so we've got the west kayaking over this
way and we've got these
kaiapova this way they're two quite
different bits of stuff we'll be doing
and we'll just
uh run through them so over to our west
we have the parnells and the dudley
catchments this is just really an
overview so you can see why there's a
problem
as you can see colors are not don't
worry about the numbers associated with
the colors but effectively
the darker blue is really low lying
coming up as you get into the greens and
yellows it's higher and then the ground
type still so
you can see in the middle of west
kayaking here we have quite a
sort of hole i guess but that is a more
technical term
and then the red lines that you can't
see particularly well are heights
storm water pipes so we've got some
quite big ones around the edges but
there's not a whole lot draining
the middle of the bucket as it would
uh when we we've done a bunch of flood
modelling so we've done five
year 50 year 100 year and 200 year blood
bottling recently
and you can see some numbers over there
on the left uh they're quite
relatively high you know 52 houses at
risk in a 100 year and
362 and a 200 year i've chosen the 200
year picture there because it's the most
dramatic of course
um but those numbers i mean they don't
reflect
houses flooding is the kind of most
extreme um flooding under floor
and excess flooding can actually be
pretty dramatic as well so
um the numbers are much higher for for
those things even in quite small events
you can have access
issues to your house and and if you need
to go to the hospital or something this
is a
quite a dramatic thing so this is uh
what we're hoping to do here in the
partners so
um oops got it got me drain names flying
in there so there's three main
uh sort of open waterways here the
parliament's drain the drain and sunday
school drain
so we're going to put a much bigger pipe
over there from the
uh west side of the movement we're going
to put a new big pipe
hopefully through there through that
we're checking place
and a new one coming over from sunday
school drain through to the middle
i'm going to put a big pump station in
the middle right in the bottom of the
lowest
lowest point and a new rising man to the
coyote river
and also the dudley drain pump station
which is just just down the road
actually a few hundred meters away
it currently sits in the ecan stockback
which is not ideal from a resilience
point of view
and also it's a very old pub station so
we're hoping to rebuild a new one
on this side of the stock bank and we
can decommission the markets in the
stock
so that was that that's that project um
this is the the second one which is over
in the feldwick macintosh catchments
which is
our better way and the intent of this
project is more suburban and rural
flooding so
it's a little bit different it's not
that same kind of urban problem but
there
is um down here there's quite a problem
around um
bracelet street that has been going so
this is a hundred year one and this is
the 200th year
and then you can see this rural
flooding's really bad the macintosh
drainage it was all about
um it's a really big drain
um and
um
yeah uh also there's no stormwater
treatment
from water quality treatment from this
urban area so we're looking to see um if
we can put some stuff in to
help it
the two pictures on the leaf are looking
up both velvet and macintosh from the
stopping here
and the design of what we are hoping to
achieve is on the dry
sort of macintosh and felt like we're
hoping to put in a new big pump station
there's no pump station here at the
moment
we're able to put in a flood storage
area which is really i mean we will hope
to do some kind of ecological
improvement as well
uh but it is primarily so the pump
station functions
efficiently because you so so that it's
not constrained by how much water is
coming down the drain and this pump
station would only be used in a very
extreme openings it's
not a routine i think one of the
exciting ecological things we can do is
do a two-stage channel there
i'll talk a minute a little bit about
hinana's morning potential with
mackintosh
the feldwick conversation that you see
on the left is really old
it's it's amazing it's held together
this long so we're looking to replace
that
put in a new wetland to check that urban
storm water
and a new pump station up there to
reduce the flooding um from
from branch bridge and push it down to
the big push it out of rising main
uh to the kaikou river now this is only
preliminary design we are all still
playing with this
uh layout we're doing a bit more
modelling and seeing what's the most
efficient and we are trying to
find a sustainable solution amongst and
all the other values that we're looking
at at the same time
so this is what the two stage channels
this is the photo on the right is
looking from the
from beach road downstream and this is i
know it's a bit of scribbly
but this is our draft drawing of what
we'd like the two-stage channel to look
like so we'll keep
maintaining that base flow as it
currently is and then have a much lower
channel next to it
slightly higher than the base flow but
lower than the surrounding land which
can be planted and that will provide
enough
spawning habitat there is
currently a tiny area in the macintosh
that has something on it or they have
found
a couple of eggs but it is pretty uh
rubbed out i would say habitat it's
quite degraded so
there's a massive opportunity here i
think i'm quite excited about the
opportunity
to provide something more naturalised
and we are slightly constrained there's
a little
um you can't nearly see on this drawing
but there's a wastewater main about 20
meters away it's running down the left
uh rising magnets and so we sort of it's
about an extent that we can widen
but that that's more than sufficient
what we'd
there's only a few trees at the top most
of these
it's not great habitat um interesting
change this year with the east fresh
water
so the area south of the stock bank has
now been identified as a natural
weakness which has resource consenting
implications for us very much so
actually so
uh if you are working within if you were
doing any efforts within 10 metres of a
natural wetland
or any discharges within 100 meters you
have to have a you have to
be incented for that and we will
definitely be doing that looking at pump
stations and driving them to stop things
so
that's interesting and i think the
weakness is it's not
i've walked around it's not it's
it could be improved so we could also do
some planting in here maybe
so there's this very similar area to
each shovel really works as well so the
ecan and wdc are trying to coordinate so
we don't
that's don't um they should be the same
area and and
yeah it's making public it's not locked
into the areas at the same time
yeah vehicle movements okay thanks
it was very similar to the area yeah
they do yeah
and so just on the project management
side of things so we had 18 million in
funding for this project
uh 9 million came from the crown and i'm
very pleased to say that
is off today the minister has finally
signed off it's been started
in september we've been waiting
it's been a little bit stressful because
obviously um i had a huge amount of time
pressure too because the shovel the
whole purpose of shovel really is to get
people in the community working
which is also really nice actually i
really enjoyed working on this
project with this philosophy but they
have put a deadline on us that we have
to start construction by the 31st of may
and we have to finish it within 24
months of the signing of the agreement
so i feel like we bought ourselves three
months in terms of that second
24 months but it's still really tight
for the kind of scale of works that
we're looking at doing
and we've been working really hard to
get it underway
uh so where are we so we've never
finished our scheme design it will be
done this week
and we've been out running around madly
on site i'll run into some of the
investigations we've been doing
as of this week we've appointed a
detailed designer who is doing
everything before may next year which is
going to keep them very busy
and we've been talking to various
landowners because we do need to look at
some easements or some land purchases
we would like to they're not absolutely
essential for the project but if we
could purchase a little bit of land this
would really help
so just quickly through the site
investigations
we're doing a bunch of geotech as you
probably know uh
there's a pretty bad soil conditions and
very high ground water and kayak
so it is quite challenging to build
anything actually
so yeah lots of cpts and hand orgasms
investigation in a detailed
investigation for contaminated land
so then here in risk highway there was
some
market gardens there was a piggery and
there's potentially coal tar and roads
and over in the oh and there's the
railway line
um and then in the regeneration design
which we might be looking to use a bit
of
there uh potentially some heavy metals
and some asbestos at the top
so these are things we're all conscious
of and we will continue to
consider as we move the project forward
and we'll be doing a bunch of surveys so
there's been drone out
uh some surveys and we've been pot
holidays there's a lot of
it's a complicated project there's a lot
of service places with uh
various other slightly important things
like the vodafone fiber optic cable that
goes between
north and south island pretty clean not
to hit that one
and we have to go back um
yeah uh
we have we're hoping to submit we've had
a priya
and we're hoping to submit our
consenting stuff this month
archaeology we've had commissioned a
report and uh
it's facebook i love reading about the
lovely watchable boys but something you
might find quite interesting is both
macintosh and fabric drains
are historic drains they were built
before 1900
and here it is new zealand's opinion is
that they would like to see those
straight
wetland training drains retained
for their historic value obviously to
directly conflict with ecological
value so we will have to
look at both those things and
ecologically we haven't done any more
surveys but we are hoping to commission
some this summer specifically the inanna
spawning
so that we can make sure that we put in
the best possible habitat for what could
be here in the future
finally we have a lot of stakeholders so
we've got
interested residents and property owners
and various
other groups in the community so we've
been out about talked to most of them
and now to you
so that's me have you got any questions
although i should say i'm an ecologist
by training so i am passionate about not
packing all the ways as well
yeah uh these big pump stations flood
pump stations are only used in extreme
events so it's
it's when there's a lot of blood it's
not the kind
so this is a purely surface water
flooding after heavy rain
there's no tidal no stop light
yes that is certainly an option we
looked at during optioneering
um it doesn't help for
the middle bit here and it doesn't help
so much
of the feldwick either because the
grades are just so flat
and there's so much water you need such
a big volume
um and the groundwater table is so high
you just have to have that so it's a
it's a big catchment that's bigger
town amazing so it's all water coming
off the streets
oh no there is some contributions from
down to the southwest macintosh's runs
all the way too
wooden yeah
that's fine any other questions
sylvia i've got a couple uh
excellent presentation thank you um
yeah let's go back to that macintosh's
picture
yeah it's crap quality water
constantly flowing into our water
systems
yeah and that's what we're we're
battling with constantly doesn't matter
where the drains coming from
it's looking like they're entering our
waterways and
if we can't incorporate as part of our
rural drainage network or
our urban danger drainage network some
way of filtering this water appreciate
can't be done at high flows but
in your secondary levels by increasing
wetland areas is
my pet topic then
we just aren't going anywhere i know the
treatment for
point source contaminants we can work on
upstream but we've got to have something
within the network
now that's not something you want to
hear when you've got such a tight
timeline
timeline but i think it's very valid in
terms of forward thinking
is it going to be valid and actually i
can say um we are looking
at negotiating with purchasing
and if we are successful in that um we
would be able to look at maybe a wider
you know yeah
sorry dixon's down there not sure
yeah the other one was i see you
talked to mkt as part of that process
was there any
liaison with the local rooney just
downtown i believe so
we started yeah
i just sort of saw your little reference
to historical drainage and
got these historical values well i'd say
from the rooney's point of view
they've just been bad news ever since i
got put in because i've lost
all their swamps and all the wetlands so
um
that's just a point of view from the
other side i mean when i was sitting out
here just new zealand i was
yeah i do appreciate that they are there
they are there to protect
them here attention yeah a straight
frame training and wheat levels
yeah cool right you can have both
any more questions of sylvia
okay
could we have a mover please to accept
this report
john thank you secondary please erin
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
murray committee updates
uh yours
keep things old to speak from here if
everyone can hear me okay all right
because we'll probably have people using
the computer
various points um moving through these
reasonably quickly we've got a couple of
things that may take a wee bit more time
so
um proposed plan change seven there's
probably other people in the room that
could speak to it more than i
but that it went through to december the
fourth
uh several of you have been participants
in that process so
that's probably the major thing to
clarify for those that are interested
and um something i'll probably take
advantage of over the
the holiday period is that there's a for
those that have got their gender papers
there's a youtube channel for the
hearing
so you can actually go and view i
couldn't think of anything more boring
[Music]
apparently a number of the submissions
are probably worth looking at and
so um it's great that that's there as a
record for us to
as a reference so that's probably the
main thing i don't know if anyone wants
to add anything
in terms of the plan change kevin b
can i ask when ecan expects the
report from the panel to come come with
its recommendations
i could get as far as february
26 which is when the commissioners are
adjourned to
a return and there should be a report
from ecan in terms of
uh possibly whoever the office is
running it with replies
in responses to questions raised during
the
submission process
thank you i'm concurred with that that's
a good
estimate of when it when it's coming
through knowing that yeah that seemed
very busy amber and responding and
producing that in february
okay if that covers clean change seven
uh the regional committee
caroline to um the next meeting
final meeting of the year is tomorrow
does anything you want to add
carolina um not really but i've put in
there about discussion about the lessons
learned in the last 10 years but then
when i read the agenda that i write the
other day it
seemed like they were putting out the
last 10 years of the regional committee
rather than the cwns
that's a bit underwhelming
because i've written out a whole lot of
what i thought were quite useful points
about the cwns but
um so it might just be a bit of a naval
gazing um exercise instead of something
a bit more constructive
so we probably don't need to discuss
that that's what i'm getting too
but it does sound like the regional
committee is
probably going to be an independent
advisory panel or a
scaled-down version of the regional
committee it seems
unlikely that it will remain in its
current form
and that will probably entail removal of
the zone committee
members and provision of other
opportunities for zone committees to
work together or communicate with each
other and
yeah so that should be hopefully useful
because that falls out yeah so we'll
just see how that all stands out
there's still ongoing discussion so that
the options come to council
um and council make a decision as to
what it looks like
yeah um i think it's might even be
discussed
well if it's not the city so to become a
group but i'm pretty sure it's this
there's
is
what the regional committee will look
for yes the council will decide
there's lots of different views
[Applause]
thanks carolyn evening um following on
from that i
just the next one's around the zone
committee review and just giving the
committee an update
on that process so um
the feedback that's been received
over the course of the year today has
gone through to the mural forum
on the 27th of november by way of
um a an endorsement for that
revised terms of reference and
leadership priorities
um that will then find on from what
council hands has just touched on
um will be presented to environment
canterbury on thursday
so the next step after that will be then
to inform
territorial authorities runanga and zone
committees in terms of
of that revised terms of reference so
will will be in touch and circulating
that i
expect before christmas and obviously
something we'll come back to in the new
year
the other addition to that which i
didn't have at the time of putting the
papers together but i now have gotten
breaking news at the last meeting i
raised
the kite because i thought it better
that you have the kite raised
that the option of crochet city council
having it represented on this committee
had been moved
through his own community review process
that was
presented to the city council along with
a range of other options and feedback um
to the infrastructure of one of their
officers with the infrastructure
committee
and the recommendations that were agreed
upon was for
the croatia city council to continue the
representatives
on its current three committees which is
christchurch melton banks peninsula and
selma so um
as we discuss by email we can keep the
powder dry and we
don't need to follow up on that issue
any further in terms of that not being
an option that's been put forward
through review
so um that's i guess just the other
update that's happened since drafting
the papers and getting here this
um afternoon there any other questions
on that before we move on to
working groups um just one thing where i
just noticed in the
regional committee notes around that
review something about um it sounded
like it was looking quite positive to
have
for a youth member to be recruited onto
each stone committee
but that one thing i was going to
mention tomorrow
was that the youth could only come from
particular groups like the ecan what do
they call it
in like specific groups and i just
wondered why
only those specific groups
[Applause]
i think yeah as a default it's
those as you'll recall we had the two
youth members come on from
the rugby to to talk to you as a
committee about it during that
phase of providing feedback so that's
been quite a consistent
feature you won't be surprised that all
the committees have been quite
um enthusiastic about that option those
structures are in place in terms of
having that
you thought it was a way to i guess
encourage
and have youth members join
into the cwms process i would imagine
i can probably say with some level of
confidence they're not speaking out of
line that
when we get into the new year and and
get to look at that that
exercise and if you as a community go
yes we'd actually like to follow through
on that then
i imagine there would be some scope
to discuss how we would do that i.e
would we
talk to local high schools or something
you know so there'll be some criteria
one of the
some practical things that will be
that'll come through that i'm aware of
is that
the tenure of the youth zone committee
member
on the committee will be one one year as
a default just because one year when
you're
17 versus whatever age we may be
is perhaps a wee bit more so rather than
three year term it's one year term so
as a consequence there's there will be
some flexibility i imagine in terms of
as of as being able to look at youth
membership and something around
mentioned i think during that feedback
was the option of them being like a full
member that they can you know they can
participate rather than just being sort
of more in an observant
sort of status again i think that's
something the companies will have the
capacity to
influence so i think there will be some
scope
ensure caroline to look at that but the
youth rope i guess there is is a
is a structure by which we can actually
go about introducing formalising youth
being part of the cwms
so that will be kind of a starting
engagement around that
yeah and i'm sure those kids will be you
know ideal candidates but i just felt
like
why limit it to those
up on what you're saying and it says um
so one youth representative may be added
to the committee on the recommendation
of the zone committee
it says where youth representatives are
recommended expressions of interest will
be drawn from
environment categories youth raw food
territorial authorities youth councils
and roonaka um and then confirmed and i
was just thinking what that actually
means
in terms of expressions of interest will
be
drawn from wouldn't preclude
the youth raw poo recommending something
area but it sounds like it has to come
through there
but but they could go wider yes as well
and i think what that's really getting
is what murray says is that
the idea is that they're part of a group
themselves so
they might not be part of the usual boot
right at the time
but they would we want them to be part
of it to get that
overall inclusiveness
if that makes sense thank you
i'm not a lawyer
of terms of reference i saw so i might
have missed that piece
but thanks nice question
okay um working groups with the
committee now
with cameron not being here today um he
was going to
um just through time to memphis he said
i'll provide an update
here at the meeting uh i do notice a
quick email i don't know if i went to
all of this or
student line just saying that he's
looking to catch up with
erin and windy and then provide a
sort of an update through to all the
committee by email i imagine
before christmas just um apologies for
from cameron for not being here that's
right
a bit more time just to catch up with
with the working group and then provide
something from there
yeah there's a lot going on with the
background
and the background with the next
generation and whatever you say
that's just going to be clarified a bit
as well yeah
yeah that's certainly kind of alluded to
that but that's
well we're here we should be focusing
[Applause]
[Music]
um biodiversity okay thank you
um yes so there's some notes in the
agenda
i guess that the main point postman was
that that clinical
guard was presented with community
service award
um
and someone that came out of the
biodiversity working group sort of
machinations
considerations so we're very pleased to
see that went through
the system do you want to mention the
annual revolt so given that one of the
other
items that we haven't got here in
breaking news is a copy of the annual
port to review but we're in drafting but
we just thought that one of us that
would be probably quite a
good story to run in terms of the fact
that um
even putting that forward with something
that was initiated by this committee
and and in the zone committee revised
terms of reference and
what the roles and purpose of committees
are that's exactly the sort of thing
that
zone committee should be doing so i
think it's a nice way to recognize
nick's contribution to the community but
also the role of this company's play to
bring that forward so
we'll make that one of the stories thank
you um so we did meet on the 13th of
november
um one of the things we talked about was
a talk by anthony schaffelt and sticks
with her
notifications there and restoration work
which we that
a few of us have seen and what is very
good and
to be very transferable to one another
yeah so that's probably something that
would be
very interesting to see some of the
changes that might be talking about in
the stakes
the capital in particular um
the main point of our meetings uh
developing the idea of the wine of
korean community guy diversity trust
um up with a is a purpose
which say apple pie look i
think what
most people might expect in this
community
we have also got some first ideas about
more detailed
aims purposes and possible
trusting attributes rather than names
at the moment um so the whole zone
committee has gotten through those ideas
[Applause]
trust might do and be welcome
direct to me and as i noted here we do
need to
i think develop our partnership with
we perhaps need to think about the
specific aims of what this trust would
[Applause]
renault is that the trustees meeting
um that is probably the working goal of
the record
and actually developing the trust so
that it reflects the partnership i think
i think you've already got two running
reps
we need to be sure that we've got your
input into
what the trust should look like okay
well i guess ruling our support is
really important to the whole concept so
we want to be sure that
women are behind the idea so don't go to
them with a blank sheet
of paper talk to john he'll he'll
identify their specific names
and what they want from the trust and
then yeah
get that in writing with things
go and talk to john
you don't need
um the coastal catchments um caroline's
again provided a
update on the progress there i don't
know if you want
anything further no it just is is red
hopefully we'll be looking to have
another um possibly a field trip
at the end of january um that will
be focusing on plants that are suitable
to be planted in
saline environments because people are
worried about spending a whole lot of
money on
planting doing riparian qualities and
then that then the seedling was coming
further up the waterways
it's going to die so perhaps going to be
looking
if i could just throw in one bit of
feedback ahead from one of your members
and mr donald ellis yes
he's just fizzy oh good
naturally but that's good yeah so
yeah he's really excited about the
concert
this particular interest in the saline
environment and the changes that are
taking place
along the whole coast but particularly
around the map of the southwestern creek
and
adrian was there talking to us and
just did raise the whole issue of
adaptation to sailing intrusion
in terms of land use not just
biodiversity but land use
and adaptability and flexibility in
kazooies and all those words
so i have i did ask murray to put it on
into our early 20s 20-year agenda
presentation or discussion opportunity
about
how these subcommittee councils
are not the research into
climate change but the adaptation of
mitigation strategies
[Applause]
i don't know if we
as i've just tried to brush over earlier
before the annual report is
not here in a visible format and uh
but it will be uh for your email through
angus um
uh is a way at the moment but we uh we
now
thin down what we will put in that
annual report
and circulate as a giraffe so you've got
that before christmas
um also in a similar vein i think
even closer to being finished is the
wetlands fly which is referenced there
that
angus noted to include and i don't know
if supporter wants to speak to but i
think it's really just
some imagery to finish off the document
there is
a little bit of just you know clunky
wording that we think we can get a
little bit
about the concept
i think it's february
[Music]
the next item is the laro website
we've included this and adrian may
uh we should speak to but we have
included i guess incredibly take it as
read this was what we had in committee
updates at the november meeting
we discussed it but we ran out of time
to to really
walk through it so we have included the
presentation
in the papers this time so i don't know
whether of adrian or tim or if there's
any questions
around that presentation is provided
it should be fairly self-explanatory
it's a presentation that today we've put
together the beginning i fleshed it out
a little bit more
given some questions that would come
around the table but largely
it's just making a making point that
we're encouraging
both as a committee and great players
that it's the first point of contact to
get
some environmental information
particularly water quality information
but
more broadly as it's populated out that
it's the first point of contact because
it generates
consistency across the region and
consistency nationally as well
and perhaps there's been a lot of
development there so it's
quite self-explanatory and it's a
starting point we encourage everyone to
look at through
[Applause]
sandra yes thank you for that um
i i went and had a look at the site to
have a look at the
northern waimakariri shrubby trees in
the khaiklovir
when i was looking at information that
was available to talk to pc7
and i'd have to say that i find this
site really deficient
in that you've got a mixture of water
quality
data and ecological data and there seems
to be no rhyme or reason
why some have some sampling points have
water quality data and some have
ecological data and some have one and
some had the other
and the other thing i found when i had a
look at it which would have been
the week of um
november perhaps about the 10th
that there was no data on it um the
latest data was
december 2019 and it may have been
updated since then but it hadn't been
overlooked then
which was virtually 12 months out of
date so my questions are
why are some sampling sites
only got water quality and then
not comprehensive water quality but also
and ecological data why isn't there
both for every site um and again
and i know that in the zipper we came up
with the um
applicability of some sites
for sampling some things and i i thought
i look at
neems road for um
for silver stream which is the sample
site
and um that's where the flow's measured
but in fact you've had the
the sill stream hatchery
vacate the
adult raising of salmon upstream of the
hatchery which is some kilometers
upstream because the flow
got down to 100 liters a second and the
flow
embedded it needs road is meant to be
600 meters a second
so questions about adequacy of the
information
where the water quality or um or
ecological data the the adequacy
about if it's a flow measurement site
and this we as i said raised in the
zipper so
what exercise is
zone committee ecam doing to
review all this and then go forward with
something
that we can really take some data out of
because your
your conclusion i think is that some of
it
isn't comprehensive enough to make any
conclusions and certainly
as you've said told us before unless you
measure it
how can you manage it so
it goes
the first one maybe if i start with the
first one which is comprehensiveness
and the variation what the
website is populated with is data from
several different micro programs
so it has it's populated with data from
our regional water quality monitoring
program
so it's got sites with water quality
data
there are sites that are in contact
recreation
associates safe swimming sites and they
will only be
they will often only be populated with e
coli data or the data associated with
safe swimming
so you'll get some sites that are only
swimming water quality
some will be more comprehensive
quality ecosystem health thought which
is macro invertebrates and things like
that there's a separate program
it was set up somewhat separately it's
about 60 or 70 percent overlap between
those programs
but they're not set up to explicitly be
always at the same site
because there is a different purpose
there
they are reviewed regularly and we take
steps to try to align them as much as
possible but we're never going to get
alignment because they have different
purposes and hydrology again
what makes a good hydrological water
quality monitoring site
is often where it's very easy to
reproducibly gauge
the flowers and things like that which
may not be as representative for water
quality
so yes we acknowledge your concerns that
they're not all lined up together but
we're mindful of those
discrepancies but this is still putting
that data out there
and making it available i'm not sure
whether
i hope you'd like to comment to that uh
no just to pick up on the question of
the
uh how up-to-date's the date after
second
yes
has been designed to show state
and trend and not live
data except for the swimming
site which are live data
so when you're doing state and trend you
have to draw a line somewhere and say
you know it's the data up until here and
this is the state and this is the trend
over the last 10
15 or five years but you have to sort of
stop
and that's done annually it's a
calculation that corthron does
the courthouse institute when they pull
it together across their country
and they say right we're doing it until
yeah this is the state this is the trend
and you're right it went up until
december 2019
and then it will get updated again next
year and so on
so we'll be have
the data but it is not they are not live
data
showing you what the very latest are
because the power of it
is actually the state which is over a
generally a five-year period
or an annual it depends on how it's
calculated
through the national policy statement
and the trend which is done over time
but it has to stop at some point
and that's what law that's the way that
lao has been designed
so if you're wanting the very latest
then that's um we don't have an
automated process at the moment but it
can be obtained through environment
categories if you contact customer
services they can keep you those days
really quickly
yes thank you for that i mean this was
brought up um
as uh when we were discussing the zipper
um how the data needed to be available
and
both myself and ken henderson asked for
a report
that would come through looking at how
um
well northern waimakariri but the zone
committee
area compared to the national standard
and national results that came out
relatively recently
i mean the the zipper identified that
this was a
deficient and a deficit and we needed to
review both
sites and the type of information that
we were getting i accept what you say
but but all this lower information my
understanding is
is generated by ecam going out in
something and making
putting it through to the sun so when
is there going to be a review that this
committee can
contribute to because we see
generally what i particularly do we see
it as deficient the way it works at the
moment and i
understand exactly what you're saying
but in fact
it's not sufficient enough for us to
understand
what is happening to our waterways if in
fact
you've got well you tell me why are some
water quality and some are just
ecological and we don't have both
both types of testing for the streams
that
are on the sites that are there and i
understand exactly i mean the only
swimming quality one in the whole of
the catchment or the whole of the
district is
is out here which is um
the kilby that's the only one i'm aware
of
that is for the northern waimakariri
trip which is yet in fact the
pc7 and also
the zipper identify other swimming spots
within this
district so when is the when is this
going to be reviewed
i guess and and how are you going to do
it because i certainly
expect that this committee would want to
have
input into it and i don't accept that
we're going to have more of the same for
another
four or five years that's not acceptable
sandra just
as hopefully partial answer to a lot of
those questions
tomorrow you talked about your card
that you've been on your staff
that's driving and getting an answer to
a lot of these questions
that's what i understand right so when
you say report card do you mean
reporting against the zipper
recommendations i was understanding the
understanding you're bringing together a
lot of this data into one place
that what we're referring to is the work
of kirsty's
team looking at uh yeah
pulling to get to the water data team
and speaking into that and how
it should refer to to adrian and tim of
speak to you but certainly
and following up on this question for
the just for your benefit to tim an
earlier meeting
uh and following up on the lower side of
the information i was talking to kirsty
and she said well you know here's an
example of some of the
integration of information around the
whole region that we're
looking at and developing so i guess
sitting alongside
while we're not replacing it um and
perhaps implementing the information
so well perhaps we could have a report
on what
kirsty is doing and have this as
a regular report to this committee i'd
certainly
be interested in what data i mean tim
said that just ring up and ask for the
data
i don't think that solves it i think in
fact
we need to know when we need to see this
data coming through
so can i just correct even what i said
because
if you need the very latest then you can
ring up and get it
if if the state and trend is what you
know which is
in all honesty the vast what the vast
majority of people need is the state and
trend
theme it's there on my way you can see
it
so i'm not that what i was saying is if
you need to get the last months later
for some reason and sometimes people do
then that we've got an automated way we
are working on an automated way
what um we're talking about kirsty
johnson has been
is showing against planned limits
so if there's a limit in a plan and no
one's pc7 goes through there will be
limits put in place and and objectives
and streams
okay for that site how does it measure
against those limits
so that's and that's another useful way
of portraying it as opposed to lava
which is national so it
shows it against national standards so
this is about low
against local limits i think that will
be very useful
but but what i think
what you're asking for sandra is
something a little bit different
which is about a review of the sites
you know is that the right site for
where we're measuring
that is a part of that and and that's
something that
i think we need to think a little bit
about how we do that because that is
quite it yeah that's what we would
normally do as part of a
when a plan comes out are we have we got
the measurements at the right place to
to be able to tell if the plan is right
but at the same time
what we always struggle with is
you're trying to run a nation sorry a
regional network
to give you an overall regional picture
you're
then you've got the local plans and
you're trying to line those up
and then you've got people who are also
asking to say well i've done some action
right on the street right here
can you measure that one as well and
you're trying to balance all of those
things to go okay
what is our network in this case and
that's what we're trying to do
obviously within financial constraints
as well we
we do look at it and and um you know
we're
certainly willing to do that with input
from others and
that's something that we quite happily
do but it won't necessarily
produce exactly what everybody wants
which is often
the stream here done you know regularly
because the other thing that we have to
look at is
we're talking about state and trend as
soon as we move a site
you've lost your trend you're going to
have to wait another five
ten years before you can start looking
for trends so you know all of these
things have to be weighed up when we're
thinking about have we got the right
size so
i'm not trying to you know bat it off
and say no we won't look at it it's
something that we can and we
do and we should and we will look at
these sites particularly once pc7
comes through because that's that will
be the statutory mechanism that we've
got to look at plant effectiveness for
um and i mean i'll work with adrien and
others about
how we do that so adrian you
most of those sites are done quarterly
they're correct
most of them are monthly monthly there's
a few that are only going quarterly that
we've
retained rather than drop down yeah
yeah but even as an objective for this
exercise
if we were to get a quarterly update
of actual state of the play
then that would go a long way towards
what sandra was asking i believe
so not creating a whole new playing
field
but i agree with her lau is a complete
dog's breakfast
when you're trying to get through it
just getting information out of it is
very hard
so we as a zone committee would just
love to know
hey what's happening in our district
over the last three months over the last
six months
some of those numbers might then turn
around and reflect back
to the questions that michael is asking
us
you know we've got actual data of this
creep that
suddenly lost all this quite weed that
might be a relationship there we can
draw a direct line to because of
that light
[Music]
that's a long power to reinforce that
talking about sedimentation each month
the sediment load um in a lot of the
streams
those two bridges is actually measured
but you don't see it
for some time because it but
it's only put up every year publicly
every year so exactly i mean if you're
talking about
system collapse and sedimentation may be
a factor we could see that by the
total suspenders of it that are measured
every month and that then i think that's
what
quite a few people would be interested
in folks mindful of time
and uh a possible suggestion i'm looking
at folks in the back of the room i'm
looking at the
committee um and i'm thinking of the
facilitator here might
need to that when we do the next
quarterly report to the committee
which includes different recommendations
obviously across the circuit
maybe is one of the additional tasks
that
we can add in there is looking at the
summary from largo of kind of
state and trenders in
because the sampling requirements are
quite different and the objectives of
you know ecosystem health
with macro vertebrates is looking at
overall
health health of the environment that
can really only be done in the waveable
streams
where the shallow water that can be
circular can be sampled
often the water quality starts uh sites
are often in deeper water
the strategic point close to say minimum
flow sites or
things like that and so there's a number
of sites where we can't do that where we
can't
sample macro invertebrates in water
quality because of those logistical
constraints
so i agree with you i would be ideal
well in terms of reporting it would be
ideal if they were if
everything was all done at the same site
but as i said earlier
hydrology water quality ecosystem health
but i think
the site requirements quite different
questions quite different and
they're never going to be all at the
same time but aren't you going to be
required
to um to report on that for pcc
and in his implementation but
i won't belabor it i'll
thank you for what you've said but um
i might email you with specific
questions thank you
and what we'll yeah we'll continue to
work and discuss that and perhaps look
at something that's
incorporated into a quarterly update
section of action points we've got a few
of them and we'll
try and move around the first three
probably include sophie and suzanne i
was
giving you an alert sophie at the back
of the room
in terms of the beef grove creek
subdivision
alien botulism global consent i think
well again i could even need this
the next thing was requested at the
previous
meeting by council stuart regarding and
amber feiger has provided information
regarding the location of the deep wells
um that we've discussed i guess the
number that i
suspect sandra was around the fact that
it's on the
south side of the waimakariri river but
embers provided additional detail there
in terms of the locations
so i assume that would satisfy the
committee's
questions there i presume there'll be a
report at some point about
connection and what is happening it
would be good but
you know even though it's the south side
it obviously
hasn't has implications for the north
side so
we'll you'll be reporting on these in
some shape before
yeah i mean it's it's been a key issue
throughout the development of the plan
and
something that we'll be keeping an eye
out and
i don't know what the reporting schedule
is but we will be
producing thank you
had a future reporting to this and other
committees and councils
um the next one was uh
around the freshwind note in the
taranaki
[Applause]
don't have anything more to update at
this stage fred brooks and i are still
discussing a strategy going forward
smoothly with this
but it is a very dry period at the
moment and we will come back with a
certain deal on what our longer term
strategy is for
of opening you know all the all the
infrastructure is in place
it's just we'll come back here with the
strategy for
both determining the effectiveness of uh
fish utilizing this fish window
and also the concerns of the farmers of
whether that's
that opening the fish window will have
any water level issues
[Applause]
there's no further questions on that one
the um
the next item was around the um
river continuous water quality
monitoring that um had been
provided so they could get the november
meetings so it's included in your agenda
papers i thought
um something i've done with uh the kara
committee as well which
is to include the presentation alongside
the minutes
so that it becomes part of the record
for the committee
and it's included here as a reference
alongside the minute so you'll find that
item 4.2 alongside the minutes
from the previous meeting um
there was a query around also which i
followed up on
and i've checked with angus with regards
stock exclusion
from wide rivers and lakes um
there is if this was a youtube clip i
would then go and here's the
link to the mfv site right here i'll
give that to tia so that's included in
the meeting papers there's a link
to um the regulations that relate to
stock exclusion
on the mep site which is a sort of
default reference
it's actually under resource management
regulations um
under stock exclusion and the
reference to one metre is to
um specified wetlands lakes and rivers
more than one meter wide so there is a
specification to that so
there's more detail we can put there but
i'll include that
alongside that mfv link to that page
and put it in the
minutes for you so you've got that as
the roof right too to do it
no it's not because we haven't expressed
it yeah
i'll include it as a part of the
committee update yeah
i've got it here so the reason i didn't
include it
at the time right i needed i wanted to
check with angus
places and in fact there's faqs that
have now been updated
to repeat that as well so um so i'll
provide that along with the updates for
the february meeting
are there any other questions on that i
mean i think it was a general discussion
query at the last meeting
what was meant to buy one metre white
stock including
if not i'll move on um i've already
actually covered off that other report
that i've entered there around the
feedback from christchurch city council
whether they would have represented
wrong zone committee so we will move on
from there
and eliminate it there there's an option
um andrew's provided that
um update in terms of
uh vegetation clearance and the ashi
gorge to the okuku
forts if there's anything else andrew
you'd like to add at this point
uh that was working through the
procurement process but some
efficiencies
we're doing across several rivers at the
same time so
it's just a procurement efficiency and
that worked to commence an early
early next year
okay um the final item one that can be
updated
i'm heading over to sephora which is an
updated automatic steps
patients
[Applause]
okay
um
i do need to make an appointment
[Music]
um so i'm just going to give a brief
update on what's been happening um
requested in the last meeting so we've
been
um been really helpful having the
biodiversity working group talk through
the ibis projects we have
allocated funding to two projects in
this financial year
so that was the old wetlands um down in
the coastal wetlands area and then also
the
moju kanuka uh dryland site and that
totals uh 18 and a half k out of the
100k budget
um i currently have four projects which
are fairly along with the spoken project
process i had to have them in front of
you today
um but i really needed a holiday
things lined up so they will be in front
of you in february one of those is up in
lee's valley
there's a great wheatland up there um we
have to do a lot of kids scratching
around for the new requirements and
making sure we could find some fencing
around sweetland but
um while that has been a bit frustrating
it has been a great opportunity to work
with my own planned donor and we're now
in a bunch of your places that landed so
that's been great
um the second project is
down in the blood fish area outside of
oxford
there's a quite degraded piece of bush
that's very wind affected um it also has
stock access so we're going to
exclude stock from that bush and the
stream um that is great mudfish habitat
and there is mudfish further down but
there's not currently done
in the stream so we'll also investigate
why
at that location um and he's also
indicated
is that um he is at the top of that
catchment so we
are now rescuing his project um
in that same area i've got steven's bush
roach and
there's a tributary um that feeds into
cuba city
and the landowner beer has got a lovely
waterfall and some a bush
and some regenerating areas that you
would like to exclude
from anderson um
and the final one is i've been working
with kate from
wdc um around forest now wetland
which has um some issues with the
boundary issues and deer rails and some
quite
weedy issues so we're stumping and
defeats
we control projects for them um
and the final one i have which is
what's exactly the castle yes yes so
it's a council line
equivalent um yeah okay it's not an
immediate step um some of them
yeah yeah so most of the funding is
coming from other sources but we just
need a little bit more
and that will we haven't got all the
quotes in but that will be the sunday
two years budget
um and i just got a
great inquiry um so we'll be following
up on that
and hopefully we'll start with your next
year's budget as we come into the new
year
um
so these are all um other than the
council owned winner all the rest
private
easy votes yeah
so we can talk
thank you
[Applause]
excellent thank you very much we have a
recommendation
that we receive 4.1 to 4.7 of those
updates
in reference to our 2021 work programme
uh remove it thank you
thank you again and
any further questions comment discussion
all those in favor
carrot thank you very much
item five sophie
camera of a floodgate are you talking
about that
it's just ah we've done that
folks there's a recommendation
okay we can't just bypass it
[Applause]
so item 5.1 we have a recommendation
that we receive
caroline thank you all those in favor
carried now we'll go to item six
confirmation
of previous minutes
which was november the second 2020.
we have any questions there
[Applause]
move into that
okay we have a mover in the form of mr
ashby
we have a second
oh
come on bring it together we're losing
the pot here we're moving a second
all those in favor thank you
mass is rising
even better thank you item seven
general business i shall open it up
just clearing your throat john
you're going to erase something no i'm
just opening it i'll get you guys to do
his christmas speech
i'll say that later
bye
that's good um yeah i will squeeze a
weed point in there just under general
business
and again just thank you all for your
time and effort that staff and committee
members
for yeah but this this bluntly it was a
mixed bag wasn't it this year so
um our wee town just this weekend had uh
christmas carnival and santa parade that
was
just peeving with people and i think we
need to consider ourselves blessed
even to be able to have that event
because there's not many towns in the
world that will have that experience
this year so
it's all about keeping it in perspective
and being thankful for what we've got
so on that note if there's not
anything else that anyone would like to
add i would uh
wish you all very merry christmas
our next meeting will be on february
1st which
murray isn't scheduled here or we've not
got to that yet
had to go so mr rubin could you close
the meeting please
[Applause]
thank
[Music]
oh